[Music]
morning sunshine those blue eyes the
chiseled jaw Milo has starred in six
movies in two years but didn't follow in
his dad's footsteps right away after I
graduated high school I became a massage
therapist yes and I did that for about
two years then I decided to go into an
electrician business and so I did that
for about five years
and I loved it was really funny but not
something I want to do first my life
Milo is single and has also done some
modeling for magazines like W he's the
sixth child of Mel and ex-wife Robin and
says his childhood was kind of normal
growing up we didn't see you on the red
carpets where were you kept out of the
public eye I think as much as possible
you know I think my parents tried to do
that for us because you know it's not
fun getting hounded by paparazzi my
dad's had his fair share of it and so
does my family we do this do it my way
he's an action star in all the devil's
men he shot his first love scenes in the
rom-com Breaking and exiting and is the
notorious Al Capone in gangster land and
Milo was directed by his dad in the
world war two drama hacksaw rich boy
before how many 32 old Nick came down it
was really fun working with him I mean
there was it was a very you know
actor/director relationship there wasn't
like a father-son even though I'm sure
he you know a couple times decided you
know throw out a couple jokes you know
on the loudspeaker but um he had to
[Music]
you